on a le la rédaction sur tv fil 78
chaque soir de la semaine 18 heures pour
la première diffusion
voici les titres de ce 14 octobre sans
plus attendre
la caisse primaire d'assurance-maladie
encourage le don du sang auprès de ses
collaborateurs mais aussi des
entreprises sur les 3300 collectes
mobiles qui ont lieu chaque année en ile
de france 40% se déroule en milieu
professionnel
deux semaines de les filles et l'heure
du bilan sept personnes travaillant dans
l'une des sept villes de la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans a accepté de
vivre sans voiture pendant deux semaines
résultat de ce test mené dans le cadre
de la semaine européenne de la mobilité
le festival science en bobine 10e
édition en france et dans le département
également des projections de
documentaires de films afin d'engager le
dialogue entre chercheurs et citoyens
invités patrick pénicaud président de
l'association filiale en charge de
l'organisation et cette information pour
débuter ce journal elle concerne versa
et qu'ils pourraient recevoir l'une des
nations qualifiées pour le prochain euro
de football l'euro 2016 la compétition
se déroulera en france dans un peu moins
de deux ans l'uefa vient de dévoiler une
liste de soixante six camps de base
potentielle pour loger les joueurs mais
aussi leur permettre de s'entraîner le
stade de mont boron le trianon palace la
cité royale ne manque pas d'atouts on se
souvient que pour le mondial de 98 pays
bas et allemagne avaient déjà été reçus
ici dans la liste dévoilée par l'uefa
figure aussi une autre ville des
yvelines croatie pour la décision finale
il faudra encore patienter quelques mois
voire quelques années encore pour la
deuxième année la caisse primaire
d'assurance-maladie encourage le don du
sang auprès de ses collaborateurs mais
aussi des entreprises une journée du don
qu'il n'est pas de trop dans une région
ile-de-france ou monde 2 % des
franciliens donnent leur sang anthony
rech elodie moines cette fois ci ces
donneurs n'ont pas eu à se déplacer
les infirmières sont venus dans leur
entreprise pour la deuxième année la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines encourage ses salariés à donner
ressent car sur les 3300 collectes
mobiles qui ont lieu chaque année en ile
de france 40% se déroule en milieu
professionnel
c'est fédérer les gens tout simplement
même au sein de notre envie ni fédérer
entre l'ensemble des salariés pouvoir
faire en sorte que chacun apporte
quelque chose à l'entreprise montant en
terme d'image tout simplement
et voilà que chacun participe à sa façon
comme il le peut du moins dans le don et
le don du sang c'est la première des
choses dans la salle d'attenté chaque
futur donneur remplit tout d'abord un
questionnaire avant d'être reçu par un
médecin pour un entretien qui lui
autorisent ou non à donner son sang est
pour jessica salariée d'une entreprise
voisine de la cpam
c'est une grande première parce que j'ai
envie d'aider ça peut servir voilà
autant aider les autres c'était le cas
c'était juste à côté
c'est sûr j'ai passé le pas maintenant
que je vais attendre deux mois pour les
prochains coups mais sans problème
et pour cette première fois jessica
données 480 millilitres de son sang le
maximum mais en ile-de-france les stocks
sont en baisse constante notamment après
la période estivale avec 1,8 pour cent
de donneurs l'île de france est le plus
mauvais élève du pays pour que les
stocks soit à un niveau satisfaisant il
faudrait dix mille dons quotidiens
on a besoin de dons de façon continue
parce que les besoins sont journaliers
et les besoins vont en augmentant car la
population
hissant tourmente les malades les
thérapeutiques augmenté il faut savoir
que les besoins en sang sont continues
est donc moins besoin tous les jours
faire des collectes
au total 18 personnes ont donné leur
sang dans ce site de guyancourt
les hommes peuvent donner au maximum six
fois leur sens dans l'année 4 fois pour
les femmes santé toujours et samedi
dernier c'était la huitième édition de
la journée des dys dyslexie pour les
troubles de l'écriture et de la lecture
disent pas si pour les troubles de
l'expression et de la compréhension ou
encore hey dyspraxie pour les troubles
du mouvement et des gestes en france 5 à
8% de la population seraient concernés
l'association élan courtoise ap dix 78 a
donc organisé dans ce cadre des
rencontres avec des professionnels de
santé est proposé également d'écouter
quelques témoignages
ça me crée des gros problèmes par
exemple au niveau de l'écriture de la
rédaction de la concentration trop
longue en réunion la prise de note par
exemple
l'autre jour j'ai créé une phrase et de
la fin c'était mais il y aura et au lieu
d'avoir d'écrire mais j'écris amis c'est
à dire les mêmes lettres mais dans
complètement tout mélanger donc ça peut
ça peut poser de gros problèmes dans la
vie professionnelle
ils sont assez isolés ils sont en
général
1 à 3 par classe maximum et donc qu'ils
se croient seuls au monde à avoir ce
trouble dans les entreprises pareil ils
sont assez isolé quand
il trouve le moyen de retrouver
rejoindre d'autres personnes qui sont
comme eux ils se disent mais c'est pas
si rare que ça finalement
économie et le crédit agricole qui
s'agrandit à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son nouveau bâtiment baptisé alsace va
s'installer au coeur d'un campus déjà
bien fourni il sera dédié aux pour
l'informatique de la compagnie elle les
effectifs vont tout simplement doublé
5000 salariés le crédit agricole va donc
devenir le deuxième plus gros employeur
de l'agglomération de saint quentin
ce sera à l'horizon 2016 florane parfait
et william l alsace c'est le nom de ce
nouveau bâtiment une référence à un
ancien président du crédit agricole il
viendra s'ajouter aux bâtiments provence
champagne languedoc sur le campus de
saint quentin
vingt mille mètres carrés disponibles
pour 2500 à 3000 collaborateurs de plus
dans les pôles paiement il regroupera de
nombreux métiers de l'informatique
les personnes qui vont venir sur le site
dans les deux prochaines années sont des
personnes qui sont du groupe créé coller
ça et qu'ils travaillent actuellement
dans d'autres villes que saint quentin
en yvelines principalement au kremlin
bicêtre et à courbevoie pas de plan
d'embauchés massives prévues le site va
être réorganisée et réaménagé afin
d'être plus attractif
l'objectif est de faciliter les échanges
entre les différentes entités du groupe
est de créer une communauté au sein du
campus à terme l'enjeu est également
d'un puce et plus d'activités et de
dynamisme autour des métiers
technologiques nous concentrons ici à
saint quentin un maximum d'emplois
informatique
quand une entreprise comme une banque
emploie une personne en interne sur
l'informatique en général elles
dépensent l'équivalent pour avoir une
personne en externe
donc plus on a deux mondes en interne
ici plus de la même façon on donne du
chiffre d'affaires à des ss2i qui
travaillent avec nous cette implication
sur le territoire pourrait inciter
d'autres entreprises à s'installer à
saint quentin en yvelines
si depuis dix ans le nombre de mètres
carrés de bureaux sur le territoire est
en constante évolution les constructions
neuves et restructurée ont elles diminué
de moitié depuis 2007
10e édition de science en bobine
jusqu'au 17 octobre dans plusieurs
villes de france des films des
documentaires projetés afin que naisse
débat entre citoyens et chercheurs
bonsoir patrick et pénicaud
vous êtes le président de philia
associations collectifs citoyens de
saint quentin en yvelines pour des
actions et projets participatifs multi
et interdisciplinaire alors avant de
parler de science en bobine un mot sur
votre association surfe il ya déjà vos
objectifs vous fait de votre finalité
tout d'abord je ne suis plus président
depuis peu j'étais coprésident et
cofondateur ça regroupe 4 3
d'associations et une personne qui est
issu du marketing industriel trois
associations de saint quentin en
yvelines drapeau blanc qui agit dans le
sens telle l'écologie et l'art et du
technaute immédiat dans l'insertion
socioéconomique par l'audiovisuel et les
nouvelles technologies d'information de
communications et cover texte une
association que j'avais créé qui est
plutôt dormantes dans les domaines de
culture et développement durable
la finalité c'est de mettre en valeur de
l'existant vertueux est heureuse et à
dire dans les logiques écologiques
sociétales économiques économique et
solidaire culturel et artistique créer
des synergies entre les structures les
individus quais et les entreprises et
les collectivités et accompagner ou
faire surgir des projets comment es tu
arrivé le travail justement avec la
fondation sciences citoyennes parce que
vous êtes associés pour faire naître le
festival science en bobine sur le bassin
de saint quentin en yvelines qui
n'existait pas auparavant
auparavant il existe à travers la france
là encore 150 lots il se trouve qu'il ya
une certaine au yen opération d'intérêt
national de saclay que saint-quentin en
yvelines fait partie de paris saclay et
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines est maintenant
devenu avec le yen de saclay université
paris saclay donc comme on agit avec le
contexte avec l'existant
la logique était évidente de collaborer
et avec tout le tissu de l'écho de
l'enseignement supérieur et notamment
dans les sciences humaines sociales et
pas simplement les sciences dures même
si c'est la dominante pour mettre en
valeur
non seulement l'existant mais créer du
débat autour des enjeux de fond et de
forme que qui sont au coeur des sciences
parce que sinon on aboutit à une science
qui est purement une techno science une
progressiste qui a sa raison d'être mais
on n'a pas su lire la minuscule citoyens
s'impliquent véritables fonctions
prennent les mécanismes et quelle
utilité ça peut avoir aussi voilà si les
avancées sont positives les inventer
positif c'est pas simplement terme
productif mais en termes vraiment de
vertueuses version ces consciences comme
aurait dit rabelais le savoir n'est pas
neutre il ya des enjeux politiques
économiques sociaux c est ce que vous
dites dans la présentation de ce
festival
ça veut dire que les sciences n'apporte
pas que le progrès justement c'est
surtout quel progrès de quels progrès
par le ton si c'est un progrès purement
technique on peut aller droit dans le
mur
on le voit vraiment avec des des choses
du type biologie de synthèse qui ne pose
vraiment des problèmes quels sont
justement vous vous n'avez citer un
exemple mais les problématiques qui
intéresse le plus le citoyen aujourd'hui
qui font naître cette conscience et et
s'intéresser à ces problèmes le porte la
première chose c'est tout ce qui va
concerner notre santé santé
environnement donc qu'on va retrouver
dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire par exemple
les nanotechnologies ça reste quelque
chose qui est très abstrait pour
beaucoup de gens évidemment puisque de
toute façon c'est pas visibles à l'oeil
nu
le nucléaire idem qu'elle pouvait faire
le meilleur que le pire comme le
meilleur
c'est le médecine nucléaire c'est
fabuleux c'est toujours de sachons
sachons raison garder
là juste pour être bien faire vous
n'avez pas d'à priori négatif sur ce
progrès avec la condition comme vous le
disiez de définir ce qu'elle progresse
que ça va apporter c'est à dire que le
débat ne doit pas être absents des choix
scientifiques qui où le politique
intervient il intervient économiquement
mais pas que donc il ya des choix qui
sont vraiment raison que le financement
de la recherche
il est de plus en plus privée qui est de
la recherche privée soit mais si ça
devient la dominance là ça pose un
problème parce que l'intérêt général en
est absent et tous ces débats toutes ces
problématiques sont soulevés en début de
séance par une projection d'un
documentaire ou un film hier soir lundi
par exemple il y avait bienvenue à
gattaca un film où il était question de
choisir le génotype de son enfant vous
l'avez peut-être déjà vu par le passé ce
film d'andrew niccol à chaque fois
pourquoi amener la discussion par le
cinéma parce que c'est le meilleur moyen
d'amener le citoyen parce que c'est ce
qui fait jouer l'imaginaire d'abord
parce que là on n'ait pas simplement sur
du documentaire bien souvent il ya des
documentaires également mais on voit les
le visuel c'est quand même le sens
dominant chez l'homme ces visuels on
peut nous raconter tout ce qu'on voudra
si on n'a pas vu si on n'a pas ressenti
on n'est pas touché donc pour ça que non
seulement on fait du débat apparat
autour des films et on fait intervenir
dans ce débat soit les réalisateurs dont
qui sont allés au coeur de la chose soit
des scientifiques qui sont experts de la
chose hier soir c'était jacques testart
qui par ailleurs est président d'honneur
la fondation sciences citoyennes mais
qui est quand même un biologiste le papa
du premier bébé embryons donc la
procréation assistée icaunais
effectivement c'est un sujet d'actualité
et qui fait beaucoup parler on imagine
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de discussion
animée hier autour de ces problématiques
là justement les scientifiques viennent
facilement se prêter au jeu parce que le
but c'est d'intéresser les citoyens
mais ce que les scientifiques ont aussi
envie on remette en cause en question
qu'on questionne sur le bien fondé de
certaines recherches certains progrès en
une scientifique engagé oui sauf qu'ils
sont peu nombreux on en discutait hier
soir avec monsieur testard c'est surtout
des scientifiques qui sont à la retraite
qui tout d'un coup prennent en compte
les enjeux les chercheurs aujourd'hui ne
prennent pas le poids des choses c'est
étonnant parce que ils sont quand même
les premiers artisans mais il n'y a pas
de conscience aujourd'hui une faible
conscience
c'est vraiment un problème alors après
on peut nous dire oui le principe de
précaution c'est du précautionnisme non
c'est ce qui nous oblige à faire une
science qui soit responsable et donc de
voir non pas à court terme mais de voir
un long terme tous les enjeux il ya des
projections jusqu'au 17 octobre pour la
dixième édition de ce festival pour la
première fois à saint quentin en
yvelines les différentes adresses
internet qui s'affiche pour que vous
puissiez de consulter la totalité des
dates et des rendez-vous qui sont
proposées demain soir par exemple il
sera question au grenier à sel est de la
fraction du vivant avec la possibilité
de créer des séquences d'apn voire de
données via de nouvelles cellules
on va parler de cette thématique
peut-être qui aura lieu demain de la
biologie de synthèse oui avec le
week-end l'entreprise serait la biologie
de synthèse par exemple il ya un grand
un scientifique américain qui s'appelle
craig nature qui a essayé on m'a dit que
ça avait échoué mais j'ai pas vérifié
depuis de créer des bactéries donc se
fabriquer le vivent comme si on devenait
un véritable démiurge et pourquoi pas
mais voyons les choses avec les
résultats c'est quand même ça pose de
véritables problèmes parce que est ce
que on veut fabriquer un vivant pour
notre propre intérêt d'une façon
anthropocentrique sans voir les
conséquences que cela peut avoir donc ça
nécessite une recherche longue et parce
c'est pas une petite recherche
là il ya des enjeux et si on est
uniquement dans une philosophie
utilitariste se pose vraiment un
problème
ça va de même avec le consumérisme et on
est dans une haie un égoïsme au stade
sociétal macroéconomique que l'intérêt
général soit également source de
productivité économique soit mais
attention les ya des limites
j'imagine que vous n'avez vous n'avez
pas la prétention mais répondre à ces
questions là on aussi peu de temps c'est
possible ça fait avancer le débat à
l'issue du débat les positions de chacun
évolue ça dépend complètement du public
c'est vraiment très variable et pour les
rendez vous ont lieu jusqu'à présent par
exemple comme pour l'instant c'est que
je m'y attendais c'est que c'est surtout
des gens qui sont déjà soit convaincu
souad et des professionnels des
scientifiques mais que c'est encore un
peu de l'entretoit donc la dynamique qui
je les charges ces grands points grand
public la dynamique je veux institué à
partir de cet accueil de ce festival
c'est une dynamique qui va se traduire
par un dispositif global éditorial en
interviewant les étudiantes les
étudiants les chercheurs les
scientifiques et les entreprises qui ont
affaire aux sciences au sens pluriel
pour caen se conjuguer avec les
dispositifs existants de sensibilisation
de genre de la maison de l'environnement
de la science et du développement
durable du genre s cube qui est sur le
plateau de saclay pour aller plus loin
et les confronter avec les normes du
plan vert issu du grenelle
roulement d'iso 26000 est une norme
mondiale issue de l'onu qui sont pas
vraiment impliqué parce qu'elles ne sont
pas soit ne sont pas vraiment
obligatoire soit leçons obligatoires
mais sans punition si on les applique
pas et on voit surtout les difficultés
que ça peut procurer en termes de
monopolisation de temps pour se former
et si on voit ça que comme un coût et
par comme un avantage et une logique
plus globale vertueuse on passe à côté
de quelque chose qui peut finalement
nous coûter très cher rendez vous
mercredi au grenier à sel pour une
première projection en premier débat il
y aura également des rendez vous jeudi
et vendredi jeudi elle en course est
aussi née sept sur le bien commun l'eau
la santé la marchandisation le vendredi
à magny les hameaux la maison de
l'environnement et des sciences aussi ce
sera au tour d'un mathématicien engagé
je vous renvoie une fois de plus au site
internet puisqu'on va être pris par le
temps pour voir le programme complet on
va juste terminer cette interview par un
micro trottoir vous en avez l'habitude
nous allons vous faire réagir aux
différents sujets d'actualité notre
question du jour aujourd'hui quels sont
les films peut-être de sciences voire de
science fiction qui vous interpellent
qui vous font réfléchir voici vos
réponses
matrix ben je trouve ça assez futuriste
et il ya beaucoup d'actions donnant donc
c'est ce qui me plaît le plus j'aime
beaucoup
star wars le film de baz quoi district
nine j'ai bien aimé les phénomènes
sociaux
comment l'homme réagit par rapport à la
découverte d'extraterrestres aliens je
dirais bondir matrice aliens le premier
aura beau c'était c'est quand j'avais 16
ans donc c'est
ça va marquer beaucoup et alien le
huitième passager je me rappelle mes
copains se demander comment il pouvait
faire un tube you on ne peut pas avoir
de suite à ce film là on est plus dans
la science fiction dans la science à
proprement parler ceci dit ce sont des
films qui appelle aussi à la réflexion
ça c'est positif ça va dans cette
démarche-là des comme ça trahir le film
bienvenue à gattaca est un film méconnu
superbe comme film avec en plus immature
man donc se préparer en chars défilent
20 absolument et c'est un très bon film
mais qui est resté méconnu qui on
projette vraiment dans une fiction ou la
biologie de synthèse serait et
l'eugénisme et on essaie déjà à l'oeuvre
aux états unis
donc on peut s'asseoir trouvent les
questions que soulève souvent monsieur
testeurs dans son dernier livre sur la
gpa là dessus c'est quand même vraiment
un avenir qui selon lui veut on y arrive
quoi si on trouve ça très bien parce
qu'on se dit on dit oui mais je serais
très content d'avoir un enfant qui
réussit en tout et c'est superbe
mais imaginons une société qu avec des
clones qui sont parfaits la perfection
c'est ennuyeux comme on dit le paradis
c'est bien mais qu'est ce qu'on s'ennuie
réfléchir sur la science s impliqué en
tant que citoyen c'est le but de ce
festival science en bobine merci d'être
venus en plateau patrick cluzaud procès
jusqu'au 17 octobre rendez vous mercredi
à trappes jeudi l encours encore
vendredi à magny les hameaux
le nouveau film on va rester dans le
cinéma un petit peu le nouveau eric
toledano et olivier nakache en salles
demain mercredi 15 octobre le duo de
réalisateurs versailles et retrouve omar
sy trois ans après intouchable pour
samba l'histoire d'un sans-papier
sénégalais il nous fait plus un sujet
sérieux que les auteurs veulent aborder
avec le sourire hier une avant-première
et est organisé à l'ugc ciné-cité
skywest les caméras de tv fils n'étaient
pas les bienvenues la société en charge
des relations presse ayant préféré
privilégier les médias nationaux
pas d'image donc mais tout de même
quelques mois vous proposer dans ce
journal des deux réalisateurs qui
parlent de leur travail avec le comédien
originaire de trappes et puis de leurs
envies pour ce film il ya à la fois
l'envi de continuer avec omar comme le
disait eric 2
faire prendre un personnage est à la
fois de me faire rencontrer une actrice
c'est nous aussi notre première histoire
d'amour qu'on contre est donc c'est vrai
qu'on a on a été plus loin dans les
thèmes sociétales comme vous dites mais
toujours avec un certain recul qui les
rend finalement un peu accessible c'est
m donc mais ça a été presque inconscient
à l'occasion de la semaine de la
mobilité la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines proposait
de relever à relever le défi de semaine
sans ma voiture jusqu'au 26 septembre
plusieurs salariés ont tenté de laisser
leur véhicule au garage
nous avions rencontré à quelques
volontaires voici le bilan qu'ils font
de cette opération aujourd'hui clair
cambier économique et écologique
les modes de transports alternatifs ont
pourtant encore du mal à concurrencer la
traditionnelle voiture pour se motiver
et sauter le pas jean pierre avait
profité d'un défi lancé par la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin
deux semaines sans ma voiture son choix
s'était porté sur le covoiturage et les
transports en commun dorcé son domicile
à magny les hameaux son bureau avec le
covoiturage la première semaine ça s'est
très bien passé on a pu
alternativement covoiturer la deuxième
semaine c'était un petit peu plus
difficile parce que j'ai pas de bus
direct et j'avais en plus après eu un
quart d'heure de marche et bien là ça me
prenait ont tous une heure et quart
j'espère vraiment très difficile
d'accepter de doubler son temps de
trajet céline une autre participante
avait préféré le vélo électrique pour
rejoindre guyancourt d'elancourt
elle avait profité d'une météo clémente
je me suis tenu vraiment la première
semaine la deuxième semaine
j'ai fini par abandonner le vendredi
parce que là il fallait ramener les
courses et la première semaine c'est
vrai que j'étais allé faire les courses
à pied et la deuxième fois je me suis
dit non cette fois je prends la voiture
un petit écart qu'elle a creusé
aujourd'hui céline a repris la voiture
car elle n'a plus accès aux vélos
électriques qui lui étaient prêtés le
ton idée le pool de vélo qu'on a
actuellement dans l'entreprise en fait
on a moins utilisé que pendant midi
alors j'essaye de militer pour qu'on
puisse les deux fois pour rentrer chez
nous ça a l'air d'être en bonne voie et
je pense qu'effectivement 600 à dispo
moi je les utiliserai une à deux fois
par semaine
jean pierre n'a pas complètement changé
ses habitudes non plus et au volant de
sa voiture que nous l'avons retrouvée
cette semaine mon covoitureurs est en
déplacement
et puis la semaine prochaine on
reprendra le covoiturage de nouveaux
défis devrait être lancé à plus grande
échelle dans les entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines et jean-pierre
compte bien en faire la promotion
même si parfois ça débouchent pas
toujours sur des changements d'habitude
mais au moins ça ça permet de tester
d'autres systèmes et peut-être d'ouvrir
ces nouveaux moyens de déplacement à
plus de gens musique pour terminer ce
journal l'orchestré national
d'ile-de-france qui entame une résidence
d'une saison entière à plaisir pour se
faire connaître les musiciens ont donné
une prestation samedi après midi en
plaine galerie commerciale marchande
catherine gélato patrick jacques de
dixmude
il s'installe au fur et à mesure en
quelques minutes ses musiciens de
l'orchestré national d'île de france
prennent place en plein coeur de
galeries marchandes étonnant et c'est
avec un air de west side story qu'il
entraîne les spectateurs dans un flash
mob
venir perturber les gens dans leur
quotidien c'est vraiment ça l'idée est
de leur de leur rappeler que la musique
il entende partout dans les films ils
l'entendent dans l'ordre dans un univers
mais qu' il est bien devenir aussi en
conserve même ne serait-ce que quatre
minutes de jeu il ya eu un travail
considérable de chacun des instruments
et ensuite des instruments tous ensemble
des instrumentistes pour pouvoir parer
ce mini concert
une opération séduction pour leur caisse
nationale de france qui s'installe pour
plusieurs mois en résidence à plaisir
chasse au fabuleux hausse ordinaire
toujours agréable c'est vrai qu'on va
faire ses courses et puis on voit ça on
y va à coire j'aurais aimé que ça dure
un peu plus longtemps et pouvoir
découvrir d'autres d'autres styles
musicaux chaud ça super que leur caisse
viennent rencontrer
tous ceux qui vont les écouter plus tard
donné envie je trouve ça génial ses
déplacements ses clients d'un jour
pourrait devenir spectateurs de demain
leur caisse nationale de france entame
donc une résidence sur l'année à plaisir
un premier concert a lieu ce vendredi
soir au théâtre espace coluche
deux autres sont programmées jusqu'en
mai 2015
tout le monde pense que la musique
classique c'est vieillot mais la preuve
que non là on viens de l'entendre dans
ce flash mob c'est thierry d'oise a
history et la musique classique pour
avoir vu des nouveaux publics arriver en
disant mais et c'est tellement beau la
finalité c'est vraiment d'amener un
public qui n'iraient pas de lui même à
la mi un concerto cycle de l'amener à
découvrir la musique classique sous un
nôtre
notre jour une autre une autre vue et
d'autres oreilles sortie mais 95
musiciens montent également proposé
pendant sept années de résidence des
ateliers de sensibilisation à la musique
dans les crèches et centres sociaux les
lycées où même les lieux de santé
une vraie immersion culturelle dans la
ville le jour ni le journal revient à
des mercredis à 18h pour un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité locale
très bonne soirée